so for five days man was borrowed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's 13 o clock
[Music]
hey it's episode 86 Travis Walton yeah
we actually don't do a lot of UFO themed
episodes but this was actually your idea
wasn't at this yeah I came up with yeah
most of the UFO kind of cases are not
long enough to do a whole show on there
isn't much there yeah that's true but
and a lot of mark that interesting there
kind of say me that this one kind of
sticks out because if this is a hoax
it's it's a good one that's true yeah
it's one of the very few that other
people have corroborated parts of the
story and things of that nature
yeah and it's a was a group of guys that
saw UFO and the UFO evidently killed one
of their friends and then he came up
missing four webs at five six seven days
they almost took a murder charge behind
it but then he reappears with with the
story you know that he was up on a UFO
yeah this is actually the case that the
movie fire in this guy was based on
right yeah even though the movie was
wildly exaggerated yeah and what was
weird about it is that it's been a long
time the story's pretty much remained
consistent and a lot of the witnesses
that were in the truck that night that
saw this happen weren't close friends
they were only worked with each other
for a you know a little while
pretty weird case but we'll get into it
we'll get out of the bottom of it yeah
before we get into that let's do our
regular shoutouts and stuff like that be
sure to check out our latest movie
review which was John Carpenter's the
fog yep what I've actually done
someone on YouTube asked me if I for
some reason I don't know why I started
doing this but when we first started
doing the movie reviews I basically just
made them youtube videos and put them up
on YouTube and that was it they'd never
went up his podcast yeah they never went
up just as audio podcast and so I had a
couple of people asked me it's like hey
why don't you put the movie reviews up
as you know audio only files that they
can access through podcast apps so I
finally got around to doing that yeah
and there was no subscriber that made a
comment about in the mouth of madness
and other John Carpenter films so I
looked up in the mouth of madness and
cheston's in it yeah so I went ahead and
got it on blu-ray yeah so that yes so
that'll be that review will be upcoming
yeah I actually wanted itself cheston
know I don't know if they even know who
I'm talking about Charlton Heston is
testing okay okay
speaking of movie reviews I actually
kind of wanted to tell this funny little
story you know a couple weeks back when
we reviewed Roman Polanski's the tenant
right yeah well our friend Demetrius
otherwise known as DJ Leviticus he
Ajay's at our goth night here in
downtown Orlando memento mori yeah and
he's a very good friend of ours and he
had actually he was into Russell
Polanski good he's a good friend but he
won't play any request from us he played
like death and Jude and stuff like dads
in Rome yeah okay yeah he didn't like
have good taste so anyway so I was
talking to him earlier about the tenant
because he had started watching it so we
were kind of talking about it and then
we were talking about Roman Polanski
movies and he was talking about the
Ninth Gate yeah which I remember what
year that came out it was like late 80s
Early 90s something like that was a way
of Polanski movie and Johnny Depp was in
it and Dimitri's like he said to me
about Johnny Depp he's like oh funny
story about Johnny Depp Dmitry's dad
used to run it one may still run a video
store in Miramar Florida back in the 80s
right and this was when and that's where
Johnny Depp lived at the time and this
was before he was famous like I think it
was even before he was on 21 Jump Street
or anything like that
so evidently Johnny Depp would come into
this video store that Demetrius is dad
owned and he said he mostly rented
Scarface it's like he rented Scarface
like over and over again yeah he said
and he said there was another one - he's
like it might have been death wish but
I'm not really sure he said he would
just rented Scarface a whole bunch of
times and he's like and one time he
rented it and he never brought it back
oh [ __ ] and so there was like a big
thing and he's like and Dmitri says to
this day yeah he's like every time my
dad sees Johnny Depp in a movie or on TV
he says to the TVs like you owe me $29
pecker and then Dmitri says and then he
says and that I always ask him - are you
gonna charge him he's like is that with
the extra dollar charge for not replying
and I was like and I told him I don't
know if he knew what I was doing that
doesn't return his movies well at least
not cigars he wanted to keep that [ __ ]
but I told the meter I said I don't know
if you know what I'm talking about but
if any of you have seen the wonderful
1985 movie better off dead with a John
Cusack and there's a running gag in that
with this little newspaper delivery boy
he was like a hood and he comes to John
Cusack's house wanting his two dollars
like for the newspaper delivery that
week and he doesn't have it so the whole
rest of the movie this kid is like
chasing John Cusack going oh my two
dollars and I was like that just like
reminded me that's like I pictured
Demetrius as dad their bicycles like
chasing Johnny Depp all of it that's
what I thought of and I told him earlier
I said I'm totally telling that story I
did that NPR thing yeah guys didn't know
NPR is gonna do a show about Mammoth
Mountain poltergeist yeah that's right
so they're gonna take my witness
testimony and put it to music evidently
I don't understand it but I have never
heard one of these shows I've done a lot
of a lot of books and a lot of people
have done these shows for NPR and the
woman that runs third that makes that
show red mammoth mountain poltergeist
and she was like oh I got to get this
guy on they sent me to this to a low
professional recording studio yeah here
in Winter Springs yeah it was funny it's
like where they record rap albums soo
bahk it was hip hop and then there was
some alternative rock and yeah rock in
there and like the the endo just hits
you Jam Bob Marley must have been so I'm
in there you know and I'm I'm doing that
uh it takes me like a good 20 minutes to
get warmed up doing those kind of
interviews I think it's - I think I
started out kind of weak but they're
they're gonna call me back if there's
not enough material there to do it again
I think there probably will be but you
know it's like you don't want to give
the whole book away yes I mean you did
tell a lot of the major stuff that
happened yeah yeah I started to get kind
of kind of annoyed though acts you know
I got started to get annoyed towards the
end she kept asking me like how it felt
it's like weird you don't ask men how
they feel men don't know how they feel
yeah we don't feel anything so how'd
that feel man leave me alone goddamn it
I told you what happened many men are
uncomfortable with their yeah I mean I
didn't just tell you what happened all
right
you're supposed to infer how it felt
don't be asking men about how the [ __ ]
feels I'm straight like see now that
just confirms everything I've ever
suspected all men are sociopaths yeah
well no wait you know we have reactions
and we do things based on what we saw
what happened but we don't sit around
analyze how that [ __ ] felt man well I
think they kind of want it to you feel
you know how did you feel you know well
it is kind of well the thing is maybe
she's kind of feeling like she's trying
to get some emotion and motiveless well
and plus you know people that might have
read the book Russ since you didn't
write the book rough maybe she's trying
to get some extra stuff that wasn't in
the book there's no bonus but you know
I'm just saying that that might have
been a good justification yeah cos Xena
[ __ ] I was like 13 I can't remember how
I felt I just told you what happened I
got freaked out you know yeah that's as
you would be no no yeah anyway so let's
see what else do we have - oh okay so if
you would like to support the show I
know I say this every week check out our
patreon at patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or go to our blog at 13 o'clock
podcast WordPress comm and there's a
link in the sidebar to a PayPal account
also like to give a shout out to our two
newest patrons Val Trina and Elizabeth
thank you very much I was actually I
should have put you on there on the show
last week but we had already recorded it
by the time you signed up so I didn't
get to so now you're on this week but
we're mentioning you now and also we got
a new PayPal donation from Daniel D so
thank you very much for that yeah
so the show's growing fast yeah soon as
it hit like Sousa hit fifteen hundred
subscribers it started to really grow
and then hit about two thousand and now
it's like almost two thousand two
hundred Ramos getting like we're getting
like a hundred new subs of a month which
that's nothing compared to some of the
you know like really super mainstream
shows but you know our show is is an
underground show when you think about it
this is like a like a little clique or
something well and honestly I would
rather have a smaller show with just
people that were really into it yeah you
know dedicated subscribers that actually
interact with you we're getting a lot of
interaction people ask this questions
with [ __ ] we watch movies with some of
them yeah who is that who is that we
were watching a movie with and I was
message messenger nur Trina yeah
Trina yeah how you doing Trina Facebook
and he bout Saturday it was taking
pictures of me sleeping with you
eyebrows on take pictures of our kitten
and the sink and aw yeah she's in yeah
just ask about prometheus
she bought almost every movie we
suggested that she didn't have it she's
like she's rebuilding her blu-ray can
you know collection Mia's DVDs going out
in also and I got I got the diehard
collection today all five movies $25 see
I didn't even realize that there were
five of them that's how out of some of
my new I've never seen him I think I've
only seen two yeah I think I only saw
the first year
oh and blade to finish the blade Series
blade one and two are awesome blade
three Trinity God that [ __ ] was an
abomination it was like climbing Mount
Everest
I got halfway through it does this I can
take I just no I just can't take this
[ __ ] anymore I turn it off dad turn it
off and it was the extended cut yeah
that's all that came on the blu-ray
collection
they say the extended cut is worse than
the theatrical cut yeah I agree that
there needs to be less of that and what
sucked is that there's a girl what did I
know
yeah parker posey oh yeah that's right
yeah cuz you know I kind of came up with
her in the same crowd and Laurel
Mississippi you know my friend my friend
Joey Rooter lived right across the
street from her I ran into her in New
York later on I knew her brother to her
brother her twin brother is really cool
she's got a twin brother I didn't know
that yeah I've only see I haven't seen
her for a while I used to see her like
in a bunch of indie movies back in the
day
now she's Sammy you know what's funny is
that she's like a really good person
yeah always a really good buddy seems
super cool yeah she's not like a typical
like Hollywood style you know super
corrupt and you know no I said she
started an indie movie she's must have
been in indie movies I don't even know
if she's been in a like big huge no I
think she married a guy who makes the
indie movies and she's like in the indie
scene yeah and she really is that
good-looking she was always that cute so
yeah and her brother was like the male
version of that just as good-looking
they were really good-looking people Wow
her dad on the local Chevrolet
dealership okay I knew you knew that
other that other actress that Marilyn
right Scott yeah I dated her in high
school
yes girlfriend that's right what's it I
was 24 that's right I've never seen it
you know I've heard about is sound good
you know I feel kind of guilty man or
watch it get on like forever
yeah me and Marilyn go way back yeah
yeah we all were in the same crowd that
was him that was the Michigan crowd
though yeah when I was hanging out with
them yeah yeah alright so I guess that's
enough of our shout out a shout outage
okay so like I said when we're doing the
news story now and I usually try to find
something that's kind of related to the
topic that we're doing at hand and I
found a perfect thing so this story came
from the April 2nd 2018 issue of the
British paper the Express
and it deals with evidently I'm not
really up on my UFO lore and everything
like that but evidently this guy or this
disappearance was like super super
famous in UFO circles
his name is Granger Taylor mm-hmm now
evidently this guy he was like kind of
one of those like crazy geniuses like he
could build all this stuff like I think
he even like dropped out of school and
stuff like that but it was like really
good with technical [ __ ] and he get like
build engines and just build its kind of
stuff from the ground up now he had
built one of the most famous things he
built was it kind of looked like a UFO
like it had furniture in it and stuff
like that and you know I don't know if
it was meant to be a spaceship or if it
was just kind of like he built it as
like a fort or I don't know what it was
but evidently this is in British
Columbia by the way evidently he had
been building all this stuff and then
after a while he started to tell his
parents that he was in communication
with aliens and that he was going to go
and join them okay right Dan there's a
lot of that [ __ ] going on yeah now in
1980 when he was 32 years old he
disappeared hmm okay and now in UFO
circles they say oh there was no trace
of him and some they never found him or
anything like that which is sort of true
but evidently someone is making the
reason why this was in the news recently
is that someone is making a documentary
about him because he seemed like such a
fascinating character he was like a
genius but you know he's kind of he had
all these weird ideas about talking to
aliens and stuff and then he ended up
disappearing kind of reminded me of
Heaven's Gate
remember the Heaven's Gate yeah he
didn't cut his own dick off though did
he not that anyone ever said to those
dudes that Heaven's Gate did yeah yeah
that's right they leave it out on a lot
of lean that maybe it's better not to
talk about that maybe yeah but yeah so
this guy's there making a documentary
about him they said you know we don't
want to make a documentary like oh look
at this nutjob or anything like that
they said we just think he's a
fascinating character and you know and
we think that other people might think
he's fascinating as well so
since all these UFO sites say you know
no tracin was ever found you know and
they're kind of implying that he got
into this purpose-built spaceship that
he had me and took off yeah hang out
with the aliens that you've been talking
to
however evidently the March 31st edition
of the Montreal Gazette from 1986 which
is five and a half years after he
disappeared said that they found two
pieces of bone that could have been his
they were definitely a human bone and
parts of what was was thought to be his
truck that he had gone up there in and
it was an ax dynamite blast site whoo
and also there was evidence that he had
taken some dynamite from his parents
house where I think they owned like a
junkyard or something like that that he
had taken it and gone up to this
mountain I think it's called mouth
sicker Wow maybe he blew himself up
that's what I'm kind of thinking now the
weird thing is that I think about this
yeah I blow myself to it to kingdom come
yeah yeah everybody will think a
spaceship from the Royal Canadian
Mounted Police says two pieces of bone
were found at the blast site and a
pathologist confirmed there a human
until further evidence is found as the
RCMP is assuming they're Taylors yeah
however now the Wikipedia entry on Mount
sicker has a paragraph about this it
says he it calls Granger Taylor an
unconventional genius and UFO fanatic
who had built a small saucer
quote-unquote about 15 feet wide on his
parents junkyard property he left his
family a note saying he was gonna travel
on an alien ship for a 42 months in her
stellar voyage and he and his pickup
truck were never seen again
many years later local newspapers
reported that a logger on Mount sicker
spotted a crater in the ground and metal
debris embedded in a tree yeah blue sofa
does believe that Granger was carrying
explosives in his truck at the time of
his disappearance yeah now it says the
Royal Canadian Mounted Police reported
that the debris contained a VIN number
matching Granger's truck and that it was
an apparent suicide however the RCMP in
recent interviews have confirmed that
the report of his truck fragments being
located is a spoof no remaining that
someone made it up later on okay
so there's a new documentary being
filmed which is the one I was talking
about on the news story has proven no
trace of him or his truck have ever been
located so I don't know where the truth
lies okay so who say yeah they found two
pieces about human bone and parts of a
truck and then a later RCMP report says
no we never found anything
you know this note this reminds me yeah
what's that there was another case it
was like this is kind of a gifted guy
and he was learning to be a pilot he was
gonna be a pilot and one days flying is
all sesna around and he sends a
transmission back to control tower
saying that behind me is a UFO and he's
trying to it's shining a light on me and
then it's got me he's gone never found
it yes
yes that's what they heard over you and
they never found that guy but they think
what happened was is that he committed
suicide and spoofed issuu asur made his
suicide look like a UFO abduction yeah
cuz why wouldn't you do that if you're
gonna kill yourself anyway might as well
just yeah that's a good idea I mean that
way inclined they thought that maybe he
didn't want to upset his parents he
wanted to die but he didn't want to
upset his parents so bright she wanted
to make it look like look like he got
just got taken by in it maybe he was
still alive he was still alive somewhere
yeah that's it I kind of like that
because I remember that in the
transmission they heard a noise yeah
background while he's talking about the
UFOs tailing him and it's above him and
they think it's the sound of the banging
door of the aircraft him jumping out
know that he had the door open or on
while he was talking and just getting
ready to jump out just like a second or
so after they heard that noise that was
his last transmission yeah yeah jumping
out of a plane seems like a pretty yucky
way to go and it might not kill you
depending on where you landed it right
just bust you up pretty bad they've
actually had this stewardess blown out
of those damn aircraft it's super high
altitude but she hit on an angle yeah
Bank yeah heard that story she lived
yeah busted pretty busted up busted up
pretty bad well terminal velocity is
only about 110 miles an hour yeah you
fall into like some trees or like that
now or something like that it's come off
that motorcycle at 75 no it's not it's
not an instant stop right like hitting
the ground you know the end you're
rolling well you know if you hit the
backside of a slope it can slow you down
yeah especially there's a bunch of nice
vegetation or snow but you'd be busted
up and it was snowing out there you'd
probably die of frostbite before
somebody got to you yeah that would suck
falling out of a plane another one
remember remember the hoax I think it
was in 2008 or 2009 where they a family
was called for help saying that their
baby crawled into the fake UFO below
that's right I think that balloon down
for miles and mile that baby wasn't in
the balloon the baby's in the house yeah
hoax that's yeah that's right why did
they do that wouldn't it some kind of
like a reality TV yeah that's right
they're trying to get advertising for
something that's dude I think well yeah
kind of stunt the talent everybody that
there's baby was in that little 15-foot
UFO it was just a balloon they said they
had the balloon out in the front yard it
was a decoration the baby got it he got
in feathers broke and the baby was in
the let's get to our main topic today
which of course is the very famous
Travis Walton UFO case otherwise known
as fire in the skies they made a movie
out of it in 1993 and I want to talk a
little bit about that because I haven't
seen the movie for a long time but I do
remember that UFO enthusiasts were
really not happy about the movie because
it is super super exaggerated yeah
Travis said that too he said it wasn't
accurate he just let him do what they
wanted to do seeing his paycheck yeah
pretty much I mean you know oh yeah all
right so this happened
in November of 1975 in Arizona now
Travis Walton was 22 years old at the
time yeah he was a logger and it so
happened that he was employed by Mike
Rogers who would actually eventually be
become his brother-in-law because he was
dating Mike Rogers sister at the time
named Dana and they would get married
later so Mike Rogers he had a contract
with the US
service for you know various jobs around
you know forests in Arizona and
basically what this job was was they had
to go into this particular forest the
apache-sitgreaves National Forest in
Arizona and they had to go and clear out
a bunch of brush and branches and stuff
like that like cuz it was a fire hazard
it's funny because when they ever show
when whenever they show this forest in a
movie or in a reenactment it looks like
- Sierra Madres or something or you know
it looks like it's at the mountains in
California it's in Arizona it's yeah
because Arizona would be very sparsely
wooded although it's funny because I was
watching a I was watching Travis Walton
giving a talk about this and one of the
first things he said was that was that
it's funny that people are always
surprised he's like your forests in
Arizona okay I was wrong yes it was like
a forest for I know because when you
think of Arizona it looks like the moon
yeah but there are forests there okay
we're working at one so there was Mike
Rogers he was like the the boss and then
Travis Walton and then there were other
dudes on the crew Ken Peterson John
Goulet Steve Pierce Allen Dallas and
Dwayne Smith and these guys were all
from a town called snowflake in Arizona
now Mike and Travis knew each other very
well like I said the other guys not so
much like one of the guys had only been
on the crew for like three days or
something like that so it wasn't like
they were all like super buddy-buddy or
anything like that which is kind of an
important detail so it's November 5th
and they had been working overtime
because they were afraid that they
weren't going to be able to finish the
contract you know in the time allotted
because it was a lot of work so they've
been pretty much working 12-hour days 6
a.m. to 6 p.m. so this happens about 6
p.m. they're leaving the you know the
work area and they get into Mike's truck
and they're gonna drive back to town
right after they started driving home
and Travis has said in numerous talks he
has given numerous talks at UFO things
and all kinds of different stuffs
there's all kind of interviews and stuff
like that with him on the internet that
you can YouTube and stuff and he has
said look he's like you know I know that
people might have accused us of being
tired because you were working all day
or drinking or what
ever he's like the none of that was the
case it's like yes we had been working
all day but we were all you know still
very alert none of us have been drinking
because obviously we've been working
none of us were on drugs nothing like
that
so he's like we're driving in the truck
and they see this bright light coming
from behind a hill so they get a little
bit closer to it and then they said that
they all saw a large silver disc
hovering over a clearing and it was like
shining really bright yeah they said it
was about 20 feet in diameter that's not
very big about 8 feet high that's pretty
small yeah he said now when they first
saw the light they didn't really think
much of it
like he's like it wasn't a kind of a
thing where we were like what the hell
is that you know he's like at first we
just was just a light it wasn't that
weird but then we kind of saw that so
then Mike stops the truck and they're
all like we're gonna go we gotta go
check one of the stories I remember them
saying is that they thought it was a
helicopter first from a distance yeah
and then when they saw it it was like
two upside-down
kind of diamonds and it had panels on it
and a black frame it was like a black
fuselage with big panels that lit up one
guy said it looked like a brand new
Corvette real shiny but I didn't I just
may score but yeah that would be badass
if aliens made some shits the 20th foot
in diameter is pretty damn small yeah
that good moths that's too small he
really to even be manned and later on
Travis's story about you know being
revived on a table and chasing things
around and find a control room that
couldn't have happened inside of 20 foot
diameter unless they were just saying
that it looked like it was 20 feet from
far away right they had to have been
bigger than that if this story is true
it's hard to tell how big something is
if it's in the air not on the ground you
don't really know what that object is I
mean you know it's not a car you know
how big a car is you know how big a bus
is yeah but if it's a foreign object up
in the air it's hard hard to get a good
idea especially if it's Scott I mean it
seemed like it was sort of far away I
mean we may listen we see blimps all the
time yeah blimps come in various sizes
so you don't know if you're looking at a
little boo-boo limp or what a huge ones
like a sapling remember you know but you
know we go down to the club and Orlando
sometimes we'll see
damn Goodyear blimp yeah I don't think
that's very big no you look at it's got
patterns going on it although that one
we saw one night I think that was like a
different one than we usually saw
because that wouldn't look totally weird
I mean I bet if you put that blimp that
we saw and put that next to something
like a big old Graf Zeppelin or you know
or the Led Zeppelin would disappear next
that they would disappear next to an
airship yeah but yeah so so Mike stops
the truck and then Travis jumps out of
the truck and runs toward the [ __ ]
yeah what that I'd do that yeah you
probably hardwood I mean looks like I
guess a lot of people are thinking like
what a weird thing to do like wouldn't
you be scared but like yeah I got an
alien [ __ ] spacecraft clear man come
on this come on in you know what are the
chances of it actually being a hosta
it's gone wrong based on all the stories
we already heard it might be like hey
sup bro yeah what's up Earth based on
all the stories I've heard I'm not
afraid of alien spacecraft I'd like to
meet with him yeah at least I'd like to
have them she said if they were if there
were hostile ones they could have just
blown us up by now yeah they would have
done it a long time ago if they were
hostile we'd never seen him that we
would never would even see them they
would just put some kind of a pandemic
on earth
what's up nanites right that's what it
seems like it's like why if they're
gonna even bother to show up at all and
show their faces or show their ships or
whatever then either then it's something
that's interested yes very interested or
just mostly indifferent yes so okay so
he's he's running toward the thing and
all the guys are yelling at him to come
back and then evidently all the other
guys in the truck said that as soon as
Travis was nearly underneath the disk
that it started making really loud
noises like an engine and then it
started wobbling from side to side and
Travis is like oh maybe this isn't such
a good idea after all and kind of turns
around and starts to walk back toward
the truck now they said as soon as
Travis starts to walk away from the disk
all the other guys see like this kind of
aqua colored like blue-green light come
out of the disk and hitting Travis like
a bolt of lightning or like a death ray
I always heard it described as a bolt of
lightning an arc yeah work of lightning
yeah it may be there's no talent I mean
one of the usually he says a beam
sometimes he says an arc so I don't know
if it was like ooh like a death ray or
just like lightning or what did that
sound effect again do you I don't know
if I did it right the first I tend to
cut this kind of little bit of slack and
give it some leeway because if you have
a bunch of witnesses those witnesses are
going to describe any event in a
different in a different way of course
that happens with every single things
ever happened my eyewitness testimony is
in general shitty it is yeah something
happened yes awesome thing in the sky
Travis ran out ran out there and you got
hit by something by something sometimes
I'm land of a lighter in our core
something apparently when this light hit
him the men saw Travis's body rise about
a foot in the air and then his arms and
legs went out word like outstretched
then he shot back about ten feet and he
was like evidently suspended in this
beam that's kind of what they described
I've heard alternate descriptions right
one of them it looks like a lightning
bolt that hit the ground at his feet and
it blew him up into the air like I
looked like a hand grenade well I mean
like you said if they did see this and
I'm not saying one way or the other I
don't know what the hell happened you
know it you're not expecting it
obviously so everyone's gonna see it in
a different because it happened so
quickly evidently that something you
weren't expecting something that
happened that fast you're just going to
get the briefest of aggressions of it my
my personal experience seeing [ __ ] blown
up and having a lightning bolt strike
right next to me and seeing artillery
strikes and hand grenades exploding a
blow of love a seeing all that [ __ ] most
likely based on the witness testimony
was probably something like an
electrical arc that hit the ground and
made a big pop and he was thrown into
the air yeah probably that's the most
likely yeah because that's the least
dramatic yeah all this stuff about you
know levitation rays and beams
stretching guys out less likely yeah and
that's kind of what they showed in the
movie too right now evidently after that
he kind of fell to the ground limp
now most of the other guys you know
according to their later testimony they
pretty much straight up said because
this was kind of a bone of contention
because people were like why did you
just leave him there why didn't you go
look for him or anything like that most
of the guys said you know just the way
he fell to the ground what happened we
thought he was dead yeah I remember
saying that he leave he was thrown like
a rag doll and he hit the ground he just
basically hit like a sack of [ __ ] that
he looked like he was dead and I know
what that looks like coming off
motorcycles and seeing other guys come
off motorcycles when you hit when
they're unconscious when they hit the
ground
they hit like a sack of [ __ ] yeah so
they just assumed that he was dead and
they were freaked out and scared and
stuff like that so they basically just
took off they were like man he's dead
let's get out of here and so at first
the guys are like they called the cops
from a place called Heber or Hebert
Arizona which is kind of near snowflake
where they were from and they called the
cops and all they said to the cops at
first was that one of the crew had gone
missing yeah so then they all meet the
sheriff at this one place and the
sheriff said that all the guys were like
really upset yeah you know like even two
of them were crying
evidently because it was this horrible
event so that was when they told him
what happened they're like look we saw a
saucer there was a light and it just hit
him and stuff like that so then the cops
go back Mike and the cops and everybody
like that they go back to the spot where
he disappeared and evidently there is no
trace of him there is no body there is
no was there any impact zone where the
thing hit weren't hard kept errantly not
not that I ever heard they said it just
looked like nothing happened right
you know his there was no body there
there was no look burned grass there was
no anything okay so they thought this
was very strange now because there was
nothing there the cops started to get
suspicious because look there's no
physical evidence now they're starting
to think that maybe these three guys
like either accidentally killed Travis
or
bird Travis and are using this UFO story
is kind of like a cover-up that's what a
cop would have sent right which is what
I mean that's probably what anyone would
have Sam right now noticed if I was a
cop I'd assume either that or their plan
of hoax which that's two most likely
scenarios right from a cop's point of
view so now they're like well we have to
if this dude is still alive we have to
find him because if evidently it gets
very very cold at this in this part of
the forest of the time of night and it's
like he only had like a jean jacket and
some jeans on and [ __ ] like that so it's
like he'll probably freeze to death if
we don't find it so actually we're
getting to the halfway point so let me
take a break right now and then when we
get back we will continue the story of
the Travis Walton UFO incident the fire
in the sky is in it so we're going to
take a break and we'll be back in just a
minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay and we're back talking about the
Travis Walton case yeah so they're in
police custody over yes and over the
next couple of days evidently the whole
area around where that crew was working
was searched right they had cops ed
helicopters you know everything and they
couldn't find [ __ ] now at this point the
stories kind of started to go it's in
all the papers it's even in the
international press and stuff like that
just mostly because here this guy
disappeared and they said hey a UFO
probably took him right and there's a
bunch of dudes that you know will
testify to this so they start getting
like all these UFO people like showing
up and snowflake and asking questions
about it and [ __ ] like that
so this one guy named Fred Silvanus I
guess is how you pronounce his name he's
from Phoenix he's a UFO guy and he comes
to snowflake on Saturday that which is
November 8 and he records interviews
with a couple of the guys with Travis
Waltons brother and one of the other
dudes that was there and some of the
stuff that the guy said on the
recordings kind of came back to bite him
in the ass a little bit later it's
nothing really all that terrible but
evidently Duane Walton he was Travis's
brother admitted that he and Travis were
super into UFOs and that they had even
said if we ever see one we're gonna go
run over and check it out or anything
like that mm-hmm so that kind of negated
a little bit because later on they asked
Travis Walton did you ever had any prior
interest in UFOs and he said no not
really
but evidently when he was missing his
brother said yeah we were super into
UFOs and had been for many years yeah
that's it that's right that situation
though you know that's easy to kind of
misunderstand that yeah I might say oh
yeah I'm super into UFOs but I'm not
really super into you have
yeah and then later on I might answer
that same question in a different way
just bet on how you're feeling at the
time so I can understand that that might
be a misunderstanding
and I think most people would run to a
UFO if it was down close to the ground I
think she's probably about half and a
half
I mean I think half would probably run
away because it was scary but like the
other half might be like hey what the
[ __ ] is that
maybe it's my maybe maybe more than half
one go to light and run right towards it
I don't know if I would or not I
probably would yeah I'll go look at that
let's go look at that you a run over
there
you know you come running with me yeah
so evidently at this point you know the
town marshal of snowflake whose name was
Sanford flake
really is this real name snowflake the
Sanford fray yeah I don't know what's
the town named after him Connor I know
but he evidently thought the whole thing
was a hoax although like I said they
didn't know where Travis Walton was then
there was some stuff with Travis Waltons
mother she apparently did not really
like talking to the cops she reportedly
didn't seem terribly not like not that
she wasn't upset that he was missing but
I think people expected her to be more
upset or like she didn't react as much
as they should have but you know then
some people said Oh later on you know
she was crying and stuff like that it
was just when they first came and told
her about it they thought that she
didn't react the way they expected her
to they're always saying that so they
kind of feel like oh maybe she's hiding
something or maybe she knows where he is
or something like that it's like when
you like when they accused a young
couple of murder over there in Italy
well they're not acting right they're
not acting like they're being accused of
murder
remember those yeah yeah yeah well
that's the thing you never know it's
like yeah you know 75 percent of people
might react in a specific way during
under certain circumstances but the
other 25 percent might react totally
differently if you think a person's
guilty or you just hate a person you're
always gonna say they're not acting
right that's true yeah whatever your
preconceived notions are about what they
did or didn't do right yeah then yeah
every that everything they do is
it's kind of like that study where they
found that like if they if you get put
in a psychiatric hospital and people
think that you're crazy then anything
you do will be considered evidence if
you're crazy yeah you know if it's just
normal [ __ ] right yeah
right yeah so there was we should do a
show about that because I read a book
about that one time it's super
interesting but so anyway there's this
other guy from another UFO plate thing
called ground saucer watch and his name
was William Spaulding and he said hey if
Travis ever comes back I have this
doctor and we'll take him to go see this
doctor and we'll have him checked out
and see if the aliens did anything to
him or anything like that
and he also told them but and I was like
why I don't know why he'd ask him to do
this specifically but he's like oh tell
him to save his first urine sample we
returned they want to see what the
aliens were feeling what they I guess so
so I was like that seems like a weird
thing to think of but maybe drugs yeah
interestingly at the at this point the
police are either trying to figure out
is this a hoax did they murder this guy
did this guy die accidentally do they
know where he is so on November 10th
they all took lie-detector tests yeah
this is when it gets interesting yeah
these were administered by a guy called
SCI Gilson who worked for the Arizona
Department of Public Safety now the
questions he asked they'd be basically
asked did any of you harm Travis Walton
do you know who harmed him do you know
where he is do you know where his body
is buried did you tell the truth about
seeing a UFO stuff like that
now evidently one of the guys his tests
came out he didn't finish the test so it
was considered invalid but all the other
guys that took the polygraph test the
guy administering it said I think
they're telling the truth like nothing
you know nothing came up that suggested
that they were lying so whether or not
they knew they but evidently they saw
what they said they saw they believed
what they said that they believed yeah
and another interesting thing about this
story is that these guys on this work
crew don't all know each other that well
yes yeah I mentioned that earlier yeah
one of them was actually heavily no
for a few days yeah I think one of the
guys I can't read which one it was but
one of them had only been on the crew
for three days so they don't know him
very well so that's kind of odd because
if you're going to concoct a story and
make a hoax you're gonna have only guys
that you know real well yeah and that
everybody's in on everybody's in like
why would some dude you only knew for
three days like wanna get in on this big
hoax with you yeah and even though he
was only with them for three days and
then this happened to this day decades
later he stands behind this story yeah
and to me that gives this story more
weight yeah at least the object in the
air part of this story yeah you know the
what happened inside the saucer I don't
know yeah that's well that was only one
guys say so and that's kind of a
subjective right and so I don't really
know anything about that do you guys
yeah did these guys see something in the
woods that they didn't really know what
it was and they couldn't explain and
then something bad happened to Travis
Waltons babies oh they seem to believe
that that was the case right so
meanwhile Travis Walton comes back he
basically says he's been gone for five
days nobody knew where he was I think
they still don't know and they oh they
were almost getting ready to charge
these guys with murder
yeah they well they were kind of
thinking about that that was one of the
reasons why they gave them polygraph
tests like try if they knew anything
about where his body was right the cops
would the cops weren't buying this story
right well why would you write it's
pretty outlandish what so Travis Walton
comes back now he ends up near this gas
station in haber Arizona and he says he
doesn't remember how he got there right
so he goes to a payphone he calls I
think he called his brother or something
like that first and then he was like
call the cops I think it's pretty
natural to call your family first well
yeah of course because because you know
that they're worried about you and stuff
like that he doesn't really know I guess
like what the course the police
investigation is or what has happened
was been happening in his absence
evidently when he first calls
he thinks he's only been gone a couple
of hours he doesn't know that it's been
five days or so he says now at first
when he returns they're trying to keep
his return on the DL because like I said
the press has been all over this story
so his family are trying to not
let it leak out that he's back yet it's
like you know later on laughs tell
everybody but we're trying to kind of
keep it and the police were trying to
keep it under wraps too just so they
could you know continue with the
investigation when he comes back they
take him to this quote-unquote doctor
that this Spaulding guy from the ground
saucer watch or whatever ground saucer
watch does a great name I don't know if
this is the hypnotist right yes so they
were thinking that this was a real
doctor he wasn't he was like a
hypnotherapist right now there are
conflicting versions of this story now
according to the Walton family or Travis
and Duane and them they said we went to
this guy's office found out that he
wasn't a real doctor like a real medical
doctor and we were only there for about
45 minutes because we were saying hey
look what are your qualifications what
am I doing here and stuff like that but
evidently Spaulding and the doctor whose
name was dr. steward Lester Stewart he
said that the Waltons were there for
over two hours
okay so I don't know what the truth of
the matter is now by the time Tuesday
rolled around
Travis weld the fact that Travis had
returned had leaked out to the press so
of course everybody's you know kind of
trying to converge on him then there was
all this other kind of [ __ ] now they
actually did do a medical exam on him
now they said that he seemed he had lost
some weight because he said well he
didn't remember much of anything but you
know obviously he hadn't really been
eating that much over the past five days
they said other than that he seemed in
very good health
the only two weird things they found
were a small red spot at the crease of
his right elbow almost like a hypodermic
injection site although it wasn't on a
vein okay so it should be noted no there
was no evidence of drugs or anything
like that in his system so you know
anybody who said oh he injected himself
with something that had some kind of
hallucination or something evidently
they didn't find any drugs in his system
they also said that his urine which you
know I guess they did check that they
said that it lacked ketones they said
that was strange because if he hadn't
been eating for five
days and they said it seemed that he
hadn't been because he lost some weight
then his body should have been breaking
down fats and things like that to have
calories to burn and so there should
have been very high ketone levels in his
urine but there was not that was very
low so they thought that was very
strange but they couldn't figure out why
that could be so now comes the part
where they asked Travis about what he
remembered about the time he was missing
now like I said yeah he thought that
he'd only been gone for a couple of
hours and was kind of evidently was
shocked that he found out that had been
five days he said the last thing he
remembered he said I remember being
struck by the light when he woke up he
was on a reclined bed like kind of a
hospital bed type of thing he said there
was a bright light above him he said it
was very hot the air was very heavy it
was very muggy he said he was in a lot
of pain and didn't had trouble breathing
but he said at first he thought he was
just in a hospital right that something
bad had happened to him and somebody
taken in the hospital he wasn't really
sure what was going on so he says as he
starts to wake up he sees three figures
around him and they have orange
jumpsuits on and he said as he looked at
them he could see that they were not
human he said they kind of looked like
they didn't call him greys back then but
essentially that's when he described he
said they were short under five feet
they were bald
you know they had domed heads like big
domed heads they had big eyes their eyes
were like brown with almost no whites
they he said they looked like fetuses he
said they had really small ears noses
and mouths now evidently at this point
he is freaking out he's like [ __ ] it's
aliens I'm on an alien spacecraft so he
started yelling at them
to get away from him and he says write
on a shelf near where the table was
there was like this glass looking
cylinder thing I don't know how big it
was and he says he grabbed it and tried
to break it so he could stab him now
from what I remember there was something
on his chest though too when he got up
it fell off yeah it was like some kind
of machinery or something like yeah but
I don't
if he ever really liked was that in what
that was was that in the original I
think it was yeah okay because the way
it's always been picture just like kind
of like a curved metal implement over
his chest yeah like they were you know
some kind of machine to resuscitate him
maybe or keep him I don't know keep mine
of control but yeah so this glass
cylinder and he's trying to break it it
won't break so then he just kind of
waves it at him like he's kind of
threatening and apparently they left the
room I don't think they like fled the
room like oh my god it must been plastic
yeah you couldn't break it at any rate
so then he goes out of the like exam
room that he was in which he thinks is
what it was and then out of the door
there's this other room and it's like
round it's like this spherical kind of
broom and the only thing that's in there
is sort of this high-backed chair in the
middle of the room and he says now he
goes up to this chair even though he
thought maybe there would be someone in
it and he was kind of scared but he goes
up to it and he's like it as he's going
up to the chair light start coming on
like in the room like they start
appearing and there's no one in the
chair so he gets in it and when he gets
in the chair the room starts filling up
like a planetarium like he sees like ups
like star maps yeah
just like an Prometheus when they read
it yeah that kind of thing so he sees
that now he says on the arm of the chair
there's like a lever like a joystick
type of thing and he says so when and
then there's like a little screen that
was like a little green computer screen
and he says he pushes the lever and all
the stars start moving like the star
maps that surround him start to move it
around so then he's like well I better
not [ __ ] with that because I don't know
what else is gonna do so he lets it go
now then he hears a noise behind him in
the room and he turns around and he sees
something that looks like a person it
looks like a human he says he's wearing
a helmet and he has like blue overalls
on earth coveralls like a jumpsuit
he said now the guy did look human but
he had like weird eyes like they were
bigger than a normal person's eyes and
they were kind of like gold and shiny
now he says he tried to talk to this
person but the guy just kind of grinned
at him it went
say anything and then he tells Travis to
follow him right so Travis is like okay
he doesn't mess in English or he well I
guess he gestured for him to follow him
cuz I don't think they talked yeah I
don't remember them ever seen you yeah I
don't think anybody's talked to him so
that's what he says so so he follows
this guy down this hallway and then
there's a door and a ramp and it goes
down into this other big room and he
said it looks like an aircraft hangar so
he says that now he's outside of the
ship he realizes he's outside of the
ship and he's looking around and he sees
the outside of the ship and he said it
looks just like the one that they saw in
the forest before he ran toward it but
he says now this the craft that he just
got off of is twice as large as the one
they saw in the woods okay so I don't
know if it was the same or if they were
just small flying it or earth this is a
different way they transferred him I
don't know what it was but he says this
was like twice as big as the one that
picked him so 40 50 feet and I am yeah
but it has its own hospital on it yeah
he must maybe that's just the hospital
[ __ ] so he just thinks it was awesome
yeah so he gets out so he gets up in the
hangar and he says he sees other disks
like in the hangar and stuff like that
now he says then the guy takes him into
this other room and then there's three
more humans in there what appeared to be
humans two men and a woman and they kind
of look like the guy with the helmet on
it's like they have this weird eyes and
everything they didn't have helmets on
now he says he starts talking to them
and like ask him what the hell is going
on and then they said the same thing
they just grinned at him and didn't say
anything and then he they led him over
to this table and they kind of sat him
on the table and then he said that the
woman had something that looked like an
oxygen mask and she put it on his face
and then he passed out and that was the
last thing he remembered he said the
next time he woke up he was at the gas
station outside of Heber Arizona and was
like what the hell happened and was
going to call his family now he says
that when he got dropped off evidently
by this gas station he says that he saw
the craft again up in
sky as I was like it left it be like
good luck man you don't even miss a cup
so that's what he says said that he
thought that had only been a few hours
he's like whoa that was weird
now it should be noted blegh I said when
they made the movie out of this fire in
the sky in 1993 which is actually a good
movie it's pretty scary and stuff like
that but the whole sequence of him being
on the ship is totally different I mean
that pretty much has them straight up
torturing him their pin that yucky goop
that looks like Marmite or something
like in his mouth and they have that
thing on his eye they're putting like
that yes they [ __ ] over him and they're
so none of that happened like nothing
apparently nothing terrible happened him
on there it was just like unsettling
yeah evidently when they made the movie
the guy that was directing it felt bad
that they had had to do but he said you
know the executive said it was too
boring so we had to like spice that part
of it up and he actually wrote letters
like apologizing to us like you ever
ologists and stuff like that but he had
to do that he's like I know I had an
exaggerated and [ __ ] like that so Travis
comes back he tells them this story and
you know the police are kind of like
okay whatever but then they give him a
polygraph test too and he passes it
although there's kind of like some other
[ __ ] to where now he underwent hypnosis
yeah and they said now the interesting
thing about him going under hypnosis is
that his story when he was conscious and
his story when he was under hypnosis
were the same hmm which I thought was
kind of interesting because usually they
can get stuff out of here but he didn't
remember anymore under hypnosis okay um
but he told the same story whether he
was hypnotized or not so now the
interesting thing is that even though
Travis you know even though the other
guys had seen him get hit with this beam
of light and apparently he hit the
ground really hard and stuff like that
but when they did the medical examiner
bruises his arm wasn't hurt even though
he landed on his arm and shoulder he
didn't seem to have any head trauma
he hadn't he didn't have any drugs in
his system or anything like that
so the you know a lot of suspicion has
been surrounding this story even though
all of the guys accounts have remained
pretty consistent over the years now it
should be known
that as many polygraph tests as Travis
Walton has taken some of them he did
fail okay but one of the more popular
ones that he failed which was given by
somebody named John McCarthy and this
was arranged by the National Enquirer
actually okay now there was a
controversy about this because they
think that McCarthy might have done the
polygraph test a quote-unquote
unprofessionally in that he specifically
tried to ask upsetting or embarrassing
questions to get you to get him to come
to you know to kind of get his emotional
level spiking so that maybe he would
fail the test I don't know if that's the
case or not but he did fail that and
also in 2009 he was on some game show
I've never seen her some reality show or
something like that where they have like
people take lie-detector tests and he
was asked did you really get abducted by
aliens and he said yes and the polygraph
said that he was lying but like I said
they might have just engineered that for
the gameshow because it would be more
shocking or whatever I don't know but
most of the polygraphs that he took over
the years apparently he has passed them
although you know like I said polygraphs
they're not a hundred percent explain
any rate what does he think happened he
seems to think that he was actually
abducted by aliens and honestly all of
the his friends seemed to think that as
well or they're very good at telling the
same story over the years and not
slipping up because apparently as far as
I know you know there are obviously
still skeptics and I don't like trying
to poke holes in his story and things
like that
like one guy said the whole part where
he was telling about the story about how
he woke up on the table and then he
grabbed that glass cylinder thing and
tried to fight them off and he said you
know a couple minutes before he said
that you know he was talking about how
in pain he was how weak he was he's like
oh when suddenly he had the energy to
pick up this like convenient glass
cylinder and like scare these aliens
away by like just waving it at him and
stuff like that so there have been a lot
of skeptics that have tried to poke
holes in this story and one of these I
think his name is Philip Glass if I'm
remembering this correctly
he thinks that the motive that this is a
whole hoax that was engineered by all
these guys he thinks that the reason for
it was because Mike Rogers he was you
know his brother-in-law and he was the
foreman of the crew it was because he
knew that he wasn't going to be able to
finish the forestry job on time and he
was afraid he was going to get in
trouble so he concocted this UFO story
and this disappearance everything like
that so he could invoke the act of God
Claus and he could get out of the
contract without fault okay so they
think that was the motive the only thing
about that is that even though Mike
Rogers did say something about you know
even when Travis was still missing he
did make a statement like oh I guess I'm
not gonna finish the job now or anything
like that but maybe it'll be mitigated
by you know Travis being missing and all
of the search going on but he never did
try to invoke that and evidently he had
had unfinished contracts a couple times
before and they still hired him so it's
not like it was a big deal did they get
anything out of this story really not a
lot I mean obviously a couple years
after it happened Travis Walton wrote a
book which was called the Travis Walton
experience is now called firing this guy
he renamed it fire in the sky after the
movie came out so the two things would
be associated you know I don't know how
much money he's made out of that he does
speak at various UFO conferences and
stuff like that he's a minor celebrity
and the thing is though is that on
weld-on that work crew backing this
story up was a guy who didn't know any
of these other guys that's anything out
of it yeah it's weird
what it what it sounds like to me it
sounds like if this is true if this
really did happen the meaning of the
story from what I can get a get out of
it is that Travis Walton runs underneath
a UFO alright alien spacecraft this
alien spacecraft tries to get away from
it you know maybe it's under orders
don't contact those humans as it lifts
up an arc of lightning or electric
electrical energy comes out of it
accidentally hits Travis and kills him
everybody else runs away the aliens go
damn we accidentally killed that cop see
ya you gotta fix him so they pick him up
they put him in a ship for five days
they work on him and revive him heal up
everything all the little damage from
the fall you know no bruising and all
that he wakes up too early
he sees a aliens and attacks him tries
to escape the ship but they use some
kind of mind-control device to get him
back under control so he know he doesn't
see the aliens as aliens anymore he sees
them as human-like things and they can
manipulate him and get him to sit down
and then they knock him back out again
until he's done and they drop them off
that kind of fits with the story that
he's talking about right because I don't
think that he's gonna go on an alien
craft and see things that look kind of
like people and I'm not yeah that seemed
a very unusual you got some things that
look like aliens and other things that
look like people yeah all right but he
only sees the things that look like
people after he sees the aliens and
after he freaks out so I think he
freaked out when he saw the aliens and
then the aliens hit him with some kind
of control some kind of mind control
device you know which calms him down and
in his mind these aliens look a lot like
people yeah and then they don't talk to
him yeah just just they just kind of
like Gretchen this happened maybe that's
yeah talk about now it should be noted
and a lot of skeptics have said this
that not long before this incident hmm
there had been a TV movie or some kind
of special that had aired on television
that was about the Betty and Barney Hill
abduction hmm and even though Travis
Walton says he didn't watch it Mike
Rogers did watch it so some people are
saying well this was all Mike Rogers and
he came up with this scheme after seeing
the movie about the Betty and Barney
Hill abduction but the thing is okay
here's the things before cable yeah now
what's this now if it was a hoax like
you said yeah did they really I mean
Travis kind of benefitted from it I
guess because he wrote a book and I
guess it did okay and they made a movie
out of it and everything like that like
I said I don't know how much money he
made out of it right I don't know if the
other guys got anything out of it did
they do it you know it just doesn't seem
believable to me that they would concoct
something that complicated
just to like get out of a contract or
something like that well that way you
guys that one guy who had only known
them for like three or four days he's
still alive and recently you know I've
seen interviews with him recently you
know the past couple years he hasn't
seen those guys at years and years and
years and he still stands by that story
and he's pretty upset about it but it
looks like something happened I think
yeah I mean I'm not saying I'm gonna go
on record like I don't necessarily think
they're hoaxing because cuz why it would
have come out by now if it's a if it's a
hoax yeah it seems like a dumb thing to
hoaxes about unless it was one of those
things where it's just like they did it
for shits and giggles and didn't think
anyone would believe them and then
everybody did and they were like
[ __ ] now we're like stuck with it
forever because we don't want to look
like we made it up that's feasible yeah
do I think he was really taken on board
an alien spacecraft
I don't think so do I think that he
believed that he was it does seem like
he does believe that he was I don't
think that he was right I think that but
I think maybe something bad happened to
him that made him think that my minds
I'm gonna keep my mind open I don't know
for sure I don't know it's it's possible
that he could have got taken out I tend
to be very skeptical of people to get
abducted by aliens but his story is so
the story weird and it's so unlike any
other abduction story like they didn't
really do anything bad to him his story
is actually kind of simple yeah not a
lot happened it's just kind of me woke
up like you said it was almost kind of
like they accidentally killed him or
accidentally hurt him and was like oh
[ __ ] we gotta we got to fix it and then
we'll put him back and hopefully he
won't remember I would think that if you
woke up in an alien spacecraft what you
would see inside there that environment
would be very alien yeah I wouldn't
think it would be so familiar yeah
humanoid type creatures but Who am I -
Who am I yeah maybe that's why I kind of
think Who am I though maybe yeah are
very similar to us that's why I kind of
think maybe said well the thing is
though if he wasn't taken by aliens and
it wasn't a hoax then what happened to
him
I mean you know people might say oh he
got struck by lightning but it's like
yeah but if he got struck by lightning
then they would have found him
they went back out to find him unless he
wandered off is only five days prior
said he still would have been [ __ ] up
a lightning bolt will [ __ ] you up yeah
that's I mean he would have been messed
up I mean and I would think that if you
got struck by lightning that they would
be able to tell that only five days
later I think what the stories why
didn't he faced it that supposed to be a
story of a guy accidentally killed by a
flying saucer they abduct him and fix
him bring him back to life and fix him
and let him go five days later that's
the story whether or not that actually
happened I don't know something happened
yeah I respect that if that's a hoax I
respect that hooks like I said if it's a
hoax they committed to this [ __ ] I've
seen I've seen I've seen the interviews
and they they sound sincere to me and
they've been sticking to that story for
a long time without and they're not
really gaining anything from it not
really I mean I see each other I've been
getting to be on TV every now and then
or getting done' you know that gets old
quick yes I mean it's not like you get
to be this like it's like you know yeah
I get to be on radio show sometimes do
but it's like you know like so what yeah
I'm personally just sitting here talking
on skype it's not healthy that it's not
glamorous better when we're controlling
it well I'm going into the studio in
there and you know go to the studio is
kind of cool yeah I had a good time I
said I sat in there too in trying to be
quiet yeah all time but I think you did
good
I don't know how long it's gonna be
before that show comes out because she's
gonna have to edit it and stuff like
that but I bet it's gonna be ridiculous
it's not to be ridiculous it's gonna be
good don't be that way I was getting
kind of wound up at certain times of it
yeah but you know it'll be good yeah I
know I'm getting so skinny I know we're
both we're both losing we've been on a
diet and I muscled I've been on a diet
since the end of January yeah let's wrap
this up yeah it's been over an hour now
so it did yeah so the thing is like I
said I'm not saying what where the other
eye technically I don't think he was
taken by aliens I mean yeah it's
possible
I don't I don't think it was but I don't
necessarily think it's a hoax either I
think something bad happened to him and
maybe that's how he interpreted it I'm
just gonna say it's a good story it is a
very good story it's a good case
probably one of the most famous you
dutching I mean other than the Betty and
Barney Hill star I don't know if it
actually happened to but the but there's
there's a chance that it did but there's
also a chance that that didn't happen
you know logic and reason are gonna say
that well most likely it didn't happen
yeah you know odds are didn't happen but
maybe it did so you know I'm just gonna
you know I'm not gonna worry about it
yeah worried about it so it's a good
story
it is yeah all right so we're gonna wrap
this show up don't you guys get
kidnapped by any aliens in the meantime
but remember if you like this show to
like share subscribe and share on all
your social media tell your friends
about us everything like that if you'd
like to financially support the show
then go to our patreon page at
patreon.com slash thirteen o'clock or go
to our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account where you
can give a one-time donation which you
may do if you so desire also check out
our last movie review which is the fog
and if you're using a podcast app to
listen to the audio episodes all of our
movie reviews should be available in
audio only format now I'm not really
sure how all of the podcast apps work
but I did upload all of them in audio
formats so be sure to look out for those
I don't know how long it takes to update
or whatever but they are all up there
for your listening enjoyment also
remember to check out our zazzle store
at zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock and where
we have several t-shirts and a tote bag
that you can purchase and that'll do it
for episode 86 about the Travis Walton
UFO case we will see you next Tuesday
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]